she's as old as your ex-wife and she's
american again bro so i just feel like
no there is some age
totally different people in character
and behavior uzman defends kimberly and
explains how she's different from his
two american exes
yes
i said too lisa and zara
i truly fall in love with that lady
usman opens up about what happened with
his younger black ex-girlfriend who he
also met online
and how she was about to be in
kimberly's place
right now she still have the contract in
her hand
plus dino looks in person super handsome
so cute
gino and jasmine finally meet in person
you no he hasn't taken the blue pills
yet good times good times but he does
gift her with some unusual presents
what is her
pregnancy test
what he doesn't know though is jasmine
has a surprise of her own he's gonna be
very disappointed
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia it's
the most wonderful time
of the year
you know i wish i could pull an ellen
and give you all tvs it's the most
wonderful time
but for now
we're gonna go with this graphic
happy holidays 90 day fans fam
i know it's such an unusual time and
some of you might not even be feeling
the holiday spirit which i understand
but i'm sending you all the love right
now cheer up cheer up you got me twisted
and let's get into this gift that keeps
on giving i am usman aka suja boy uzman
made his first official appearance as a
season five cast member during this
episode
after appearing on the last season of
before the 90 days with his now ex-wife
lisa i am 32 years old and i'm from
sokoto state northern nigeria as uzman
was giving his introduction he talks
about how he wants to be an
international superstar
specifically a big celebrity in the
states like michael jackson chris brown
jay-z
amen amen i believe it and it will
happen
hey
you never know you never know
i've learned just because you don't see
it
doesn't mean it won't happen
cardi b went from love and hip hop to
being one of the biggest rappers in the
world you know if a girl like me could
have done it you could do it too
what
i'm just saying
anyway back to the show okay so let's
see what we can do usman gave us a tease
of his song zara
this is a song that he's shooting a
video for in tanzania where kimberly
plans on joining him i will be arriving
in tanzania later on today but usman
won't be there until tomorrow as he's
flying from his hometown in nigeria
kim's traveling thousands of miles and
taking multiple flights and she has no
clue
that this music video shoot she's so
excited to go to yes
it's for a song about his ex
[Applause]
zara is another person i talk to online
she's from america and i read the song
that i'm shooting the music video for
for her
i truly fell in love with that lady but
she could not handle my female fans
following and commenting on my posts so
we stopped talking
you know it wasn't easy for me because i
have feelings for her but i have to move
on how did you feel when you saw zara
for the first time
i'm not gonna lie i was surprised
they actually make a cute couple and
y'all guess what
usman revealed to me that he was about
to bring zara on the show i actually
wanted to go
on tv with zara
she had like right now
she still had the contract in her hand
yes
kim was option number two for usement in
his tv time because i love being on tv
it's kind of ironic that zara broke up
with him because of his female fans
and he chose to join the show with
kimberly kim starting from fan online
who he now calls his potential
girlfriend
you look so good oh my god love you
i'm not in love with kimberly yet but i
love her personality her kindness her
loyalty
but because of what happened with my
ex-wife i don't want to have any
official relationship with kimberly
until i see her in person
so for now
alcohol can value my potential in
situations like this i am always
interested in hearing what the friends
have to say
she's as old as your ex-wife and she's
american again bro ulzman gets together
with his music team
and they didn't hold back kimberly
coming to tanzania to meet up with us
man it's not going to be a good thing
sojourn is a celebrity and a lot of
people are going to be expecting him to
move with a younger person a model-like
person
not in the 50s side note i would love to
get a gauge on how big of a celebrity
uzman is in nigeria
if you have any insight please let us
know there's a moment when a waiter
comes up to him and says
this is with your boy yo how are you
fine
and i couldn't help but wonder if they
told the waiter to do that or if he was
a genuine fan switcher boy yo how are
you fine i'm curious let me know
you can't promote a song in zanzibar
about another lady and bring you another
lady bro but you don't know how
supportive this this this lady is
uzman's team continues to get on him
about inviting kim to the music video
shoot and his assistant slam team slum
tea is my assistant brings up how he
fears kim will try to control his music
career like lisa but usman stands behind
his claims that kim
is different there is some age totally
different people in character and
behavior
she's going to be submissive she's going
to be supported she's going to be loyal
she's not going to control my career i
can see why my friends are so concerned
especially after my mistake
that i did last time
but being famous honestly it is very
difficult for you to know who is loving
you genuinely ein kimball does not love
me for being from but she loved me for
real and she want to be with me and i
need to know where this is going to how
can he be so sure of that though
kim hasn't even spent time with him in
person to see his flaws
so
how can she love him for the real him if
everything works out
she can be my wife okay is he serious
is he serious
watch the show and you'll get your
answer that we will all right wow
i'm dying to see her i can't wait
moving on to geno and jasmine we learned
a lot about the 34 year old panamanian
beauty this episode and what has
contributed to her jealous ways
i'm not joking when i asked you know
about evidence i have trust in issues
but before we get into that
jasmine opens up about being an american
literature teacher i'm more than just a
hot body i love
reading that's my passion that's why i'm
an american literature teacher and she
reveals that she is the mother of two
boys her oldest stays with her
ex-husband and due to the pandemic her
youngest is on the countryside with her
mother i miss you so much
jasmine also explains what it was
exactly that made her fall for gino i
have never seen him without
his stupid hat although she's never seen
his head i was so sick and tired of dumb
ass man that just won you for an eye
and i was like wow this guy wants
someone to laugh i think she might
really be into him guys
she seems like a woman who was fed up
with the usual and wanted something
different
real different
[Laughter]
oh
i just got a message from gino
she gets so giddy when she talks about
him
we have what we call baby talk
and then i i love it like who's my
little baby and it's like me
no judgment most relationships have
their quirks but i told you
she gets giddy
you can't fake that
[Music]
in this moment she's in a suite geno
rented for them and she invites her
friend over to help her prepare for his
arrival
but
while they are making the place romantic
jasmine reveals that geno
hasn't always been honest
are you worried about the
lh difference
the thing is that at the beginning he
kind of liked me about the age
he said he was 44 but he's actually a
few days away of 52.
and why why you are so confident that
he hasn't lied to you and other things
because i know i'm always calling him
and when he goes outside he needs to
send me evidence and all that
her friend's face was all of us
[Music]
and she didn't hesitate to tell jasmine
the truth i have told him that you
cannot be nice to women especially if
i'm around
hey that's kind of psycho uh yeah
jasmine goes on to share where her trust
issues come from
let's just say one day i came to the
conclusion that men generally speaking
are cheaters
you can be the perfect wife look so
beautiful
treat them good it's never enough
do y'all think that's true
that men are generally cheaters
man what do you have to say about that
my theory is that there are just as many
men out there who will be faithful as
there are men who will cheat
first things first you attract what you
are or what you need to grow so if you
keep attracting cheaters
you might need to look within yourself
and figure out what needs to be worked
on there
second
sadly
most of the time we aren't initially
attracted to the ones who will be
faithful
that is until you get fed up and you
start to prioritize how you're treated
over how fine jim or johnny is
it's not psycho it's just
i have to be the center in jasmine's
case i think her trust issues might be
so bad that she's at a point where she
wants someone she can control
to make sure she doesn't get hurt again
because let's be real faithful or not
there aren't that many genos out here
that would actually agree to sending
evidence every time they go out so
usually when i go out i'll send her a
screenshot to check in with her some men
act like they can't even text back oh my
god
here goes nothing all right let's take a
look at the moment when geno and jasmine
finally meet in person for the first
time
oh my god
[Music]
give me the baby talk
my little baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
dino looks in person super handsome
so cute better than
what i look like on the video
[Laughter]
that
that was a lot to say the least
as you can see jasmine is ready and gino
admits
he's scared
it's been a few years since i've been
with a woman sexually so
i brought some
i brought some pills with me
i'm just hoping everything goes well
i don't want to disappoint her once they
get home to the suite gino pulls out his
gifts one an electric toothbrush this
gift that i brought for jasmine is
meaningful because
manually trying to clean your teeth it's
difficult that thing's spinning
you know at a high rate
and you know it
so much easier to use that comes off so
offensive
it reminds me of when big ed gave rose
mouthwash in toothpaste
this your breath is not um pretty but
hey geno did say he invested in her
teeth i've helped for things such as you
know her hair or her teeth
so i'm guessing he's worried about their
upkeep ooh i got these
what is her
pregnancy test
things get even more uncomfortable when
gina pulls out pregnancy tests his plan
is to start having babies asap three
we're both ready for it
so
you can check yourself
at the end of my trip oh little does he
know though jasmine
isn't about to be prego anytime soon
having babies in a hurry he does that's
crazy
can we call it
of course
so gino doesn't know i'm taking birth
control pills
and i'm nervous to tell him the truth
because he's gonna be very disappointed
girl disappointed he hasn't even shown
you his head yet tell him
that head
do you want to take it off
not yet
no yet well it doesn't take long after
gino got there for jasmine's jealousy
issues
to emerge
let's get ready to go downstairs and eat
something yeah
let's go stop your cell phone all it
took was for his phone to be
give me your password
my face
your face so even if you're sleeping if
i do like this it's gonna show up
yeah
oh good
does you want to see something
i can check
if you're being a good boy
jasmine and i have good chemistry so far
but there's a side of jasmine
that worries me a little bit but it's
only day one and i hope that um you know
the stuff kind of goes away is what i'm
hoping oh geno no that is rule number
one when someone shows you who they are
you gotta believe them
[Music]
and next week it looks like it's about
to get worse we have to leave a tip
you have something with a waitress
no no i'm just nice
this is the first time i've seen
jasmine's jealousy in person
i i don't see any reason for it i
stopped listening to you like five
minutes ago do whatever you want oh
jasmine
all right 90 day fans fam
let's end this on a lighter note happy
holidays once again i wish you and your
loved ones the very best make sure you
stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i will see you next time
you